we might be drunk
we might be drunk as long as we are
hanging out you know we might be drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
Rex and a bit maybe drunk
we might be drunk yeah
[Music]
here we are folks we might be drunk here
we got the new studio we're back we
hopefully fix the lighting uh fat Dan is
here the beer Jew
we're drinking what are we drinking this
week man I'm excited today you're
drinking bavardier which is like a
Negroni with whiskey and Mark's got a
paper plane coming up I've never heard
of that what is that I used to throw
those almost classic cocktail which is
uh whiskey aperol uh and lemon and a
little Amaro nice for the summer but
still Brown all right wow I've never
heard of either I can't wait I'm nervous
again I feel like you've had a
boulevardier I don't think so really no
no I knew her I was a black chick I knew
but I never had one uh but I'm excited
I'm excited speaking of black we got
Ewing up yeah Studio that's kind of nice
big pet my fave that's that's big I love
that one that is is that the is that to
scale yeah he's seven feet that's what
is he seven even yeah holy hell
that's wild he's not he's not from here
Jamaica what yeah he's Jamaican but he
went to uh that I think he grew up in uh
Massachusetts then went to Georgetown
played for Georgetown because they had a
you know John Thompson who was like one
of the only uh black coaches at like a
elite school yeah the basketball back
then wow seven even and he's good
wouldn't that suck to be that tall and
suck yeah how do you what if you're like
seven foot you just like work at Barnes
and Noble I know that would suck and
every Tom Dick and anal goes hey you
play ball and he's like nah I'm a book
guy I guess you could reach the high
books that's true no ladder that's true
no ladder that's true that's something
yeah I you know I know so little about
basketball but from what I gather it's
the big guys starting an order are
Wilt Chamberlain
uh Kareem abdulillah are you going all
the time yeah like oh okay over time
yeah in order you got it right so far
okay okay nobody before will no big men
before yeah oh I mean Bill Russell
played oh Bill Russell I've heard of him
like the greats yeah yeah okay Bill
Russell Wilt Kareem yeah
Ewing you yeah yeah
Isaiah Isaiah Thomas is a point guard he
was short but I'm saying like Legends oh
yeah I mean Akeem was the yeah Michael
Jordan was uh I don't know if it was you
I think he was the year before Ewing as
well ah damn all right we got Larry
throw Larry Bird you got you miss magic
magic yeah the AIDS and then uh then
then it doubles down it's like
Kobe and Curry and LeBron and Durant and
then yeah you lose it I I need the
strength right now what's going on I was
just been in Long Island all weekend
Long Island will kill you man they're
animals it's Alabama it really is it's
Northeast Alabama you get you get like
90 great people and then there's like
there's just a few tables where you're
like this is insane yeah it's crazy and
it always adds up you're like you're the
cliche and here it is it's a stereotype
and it is for a reason I had Syracuse
with me and he brings like a young uh
like intern also photo shoot some stuff
and this kid's like 18 from Chicago and
he couldn't believe the voices in Long
Island uh-huh he just heard people being
like yeah so why you say this and he's
like I thought this was like in movies I
thought this was like a joke yeah
everybody thinks you're gonna see that
in Brooklyn like no no that's Long
Island forget about it now Brooklyn's
like hello I I make my own tea or
whatever you know but there it's like
you know what the [ __ ] hey yo get out of
my space you're not gonna hear the word
artisanal in Bellmore New York right
right
follow me around he's like trying to get
a path because he wants to do like a
good Fellas type thing you know when
he's walking through the kitchen yes to
shake hand he wanted that for the shot
in the in the comedy club and the owners
like a real you know Italian
[Music]
yeah just go off the deep end here
oh man look at that what the hell
[Music]
Rodney voice I can't wait every man has
his tail of whoa unfortunately in life
there's more woe than tail all right
still good
nice boy good toast
that's really good you know what I
appreciate about you I I don't really
get this as much when I make a cocktail
but I get the aroma with you wow like
like I guess it's the because you got
the orange in there so I get the the
smell
this is pungent as a [ __ ] yeah
it is
a political pungent this is uh
delightful it's almost like sour and man
you are a hell of a cockologist
yeah
yeah here here this is good man I mean
can I can I hear what's in it so the
paper plane is three quarters whiskey
three-quarters aperol three quarters
Amaro use Amaro and Nino today which is
the best one I think
there we go oh there we go right and uh
three quarters lemon wow
if you have two paper planes and then
have a paper building yeah
I'm gonna go down like the South Tower
later if I have too many of these oh
it's gonna be healthy again but Long
Island oh dude so so Syracuse is
following me he's filming like through
the kitchen and and the guy running is
like so what are you doing here and he
goes oh I'm trying to like you know
follow him all the way to the stage and
he goes you're my friend that's a that's
a good uh film idea he just keeps doing
it he's like you're a Scorsese over here
you know man it's so cool doing these
filming things at clubs because the [ __ ]
we go through and the [ __ ] we see like
everybody thinks it's all about the show
and the jokes and the ACT but there's so
much more behind the scenes The Green
Room or lack of Green Room the kitchen
the owners the host the town there's so
much there oh there's so much and you
know uh we're in the Green Room in
Syracuse is like you know everyone
thinks like The Green Room is like this
place where you're doing work we were
just doing Adam Sandler yeah
[Music]
we're just doing voices and being idiots
because we're just stressed I'm like oh
[ __ ] I know I early show was too good
Saturday that I'm like like all the
shows were good but you know when the
show was too good in Long Island or
you're in a Rowdy City yep and you're
like I'm gonna get I'm gonna get heckled
hard of course like match like they were
so well behaved and I was like just wait
I know the Late Show was and like I
posted a clip of this already The Late
Show uh on Saturday was just as crazy
this one woman on Thursday like hidden
me with every insult like like dumb it
like no one even knows who you are
really it's my show wow this is my show
what a cruise no one's like no one here
even knows you and they're like no
they're I'm like I love when the
hecklers insult is like you're not funny
I'm like I've been doing well this
entire killing you're the only idiot not
laughing but that's murdering but that's
when it's like you're just dead yeah
you're dead inside you're dumb you just
want to fight you want to win you're
clueless you're angry at something she
was angry yeah you can't tell if they're
just an [ __ ] or a terrible drunk
sometimes
I know I know I've I've confronted some
of those people after and they like
break down they're like I'm a roofer I'm
on opioids I was molested yeah exactly
there's always something behind it you
ever do that on Twitter like you'll just
favorite something and they're like I'm
sorry I called you a hack I didn't mean
it I hate my mom my dad's gay whatever
that's all it took yeah exactly one
little star yeah they just want like a
little bit of a hug it's like in a
Goodwill Hunting it's not your fault
[ __ ] you shot don't [ __ ] with me shot
dude that seems so good oh so good that
is so you know Matt Damon got some [ __ ]
yeah because he said he doesn't say the
uh the F slur anymore which like you
know which like I had a Boston stopping
that at 50. not horrible I guess I don't
know but uh no he's getting [ __ ] for it
and it's like he admitted it it's like
it's not like someone it's not like a
gotcha moment right he said in an
interview like oh yeah I said it to
recently my daughter scolded me and now
I don't say it and then people were like
you piece of [ __ ] like I know he brought
he busted himself that's how bad we want
that gotcha moment you know we're like
oh we're here we're in foaming at the
mouth but it's it's a good thing but
you'd rather the gotcha than good yeah
that's where we're at and that's bad you
want to surprise me a guy at 50 at a
boss and stops drinking Duncan that
would surprise me this doesn't Shock Me
yes that's good uh who would that joke
about a Boston guy comes to New York
they're like hey they got a musical
about us Wicked I can't remember who
that was but somebody had that but yeah
Matt Damon also here's my thing with the
uh with the slurs and the stuff you can
still say it just say it with your
friends
because I mean I know when he was
wearing a wire I don't trust that [ __ ]
well that's true too that's like that's
like the new wire thing it's not uh like
I know one of you [ __ ] works
for salon.com
right exactly exactly like you know when
you're around your mom you don't go oh
it's [ __ ] this chick in the ass you
know you go hey Mom how are you what's
shaking you look great but when you're
with your friends you go and [ __ ] up
in the ass and I think it's the same
with slurs there's levels but yeah I
think it's probably for the best though
to cut that out because then it might
slip in those that's true so just cut it
out it's kind of like when you're
drinking and you're like hey bomb the
turkey's great I was [ __ ] this girl
something I don't know they both got
stuff
that was my gobble that was a horrible
gobble
oh turkey
I'll tell you wild turkey
my turkey's all right oh it's great and
nothing hits you faster than wild turkey
I don't know what it is I guess there's
more proof in there or something yeah
well there you go I got this one free so
it'll hit you yeah yeah always you got
it how'd you get it for free Campari
care package hell yeah dude damn shout
out to Campari sorry send us some more
[ __ ] at Gotham Studios because we we're
into your stuff hell yeah
oh man well you're talking uh but it was
you know the the you said the Saturday's
first show was great Saturday late show
you know I was gonna be a [ __ ] yeah
it's kind of like in the Nam movies
Vietnam when they're like kind of like
going through the swamp they're like hey
this is pretty good and that's right
when they get attacked when you're like
it's going great no bullets seems clear
that's some guy in a rice paddy
bullets coming at you and the guy who
dies that's kind of like your opening
act they're like oh [ __ ]
wasn't ready for him
yeah oh man yeah man uh Philly was I'm
sure I mean look the weekend in Long
Island was great it was just you know
you get and every once in a while
it's tough because like I post some
Heckler videos sometimes and I don't
want to be known as that I don't want to
like attract that yes good people coming
out by the same time like sometimes you
capture something like people should
know that people behave this badly most
people I think are smart enough to see
like that's an idiot right right yeah
completely yeah everybody knows I think
normal people know that I had a UFC
fighter comment on it when I post it and
he wrote uh the ego on some people and
you're like man it's funny like wow
people [ __ ] with us but like we train
like they train but at this yes exactly
we do sets every night uh-huh but like
no one like can you imagine like [ __ ]
with the UFC fighter I bet it happens
all the time I've said it for my
roommate in college was six nine no no
Ewing but just a big Tennessee guy and
everybody would [ __ ] with him at the bar
because they were just I guess they were
ego you know like hey you think you're
tougher than me and he was like this big
pothead guy and he dropped a few guys
but uh he would get into it all the time
you ever get hurt he got [ __ ] up a few
times but like it was terrifying because
it was like watching you know like uh
King Kong and and what's his face the
Godzilla when they go out of just two
big white guys like rolling around a bar
you're like well [ __ ] JT's back at it
you know that was a crossover I was just
like I have no interest
[Music]
Predator come on get come up with a new
thing instead of just making old people
fight yeah I don't give a [ __ ] Predator
is so good alien was so good then we
gotta put them together I got a new
fashion to make I've never seen alien
wow is it great do I need I almost
watched it the other day it's pretty
good yeah it's pretty great and it
changed the genre and then the second
one is more of an action movie but the
third one's [ __ ] dude you know what I
watched the other night that's killer
and our boy Maddie sent it to us
Matt I appreciate it Pig the Nicholas
Cage movie
God damn people are raving that's a good
movie damn I thought it was about my ex
all right have I made that joke six
times yet I drink every time
your ex is a lovely woman too I don't
know why you said that she's got an
apple in her mouth right now
yeah but no I I hear it's like gut
wrenching and sad it's the anti-johnwick
oh Nicholas Cage is like uh he's like
sushi yeah it's either great or you're
like I'm good this is gonna ruin my day
that's so true yeah he ain't Pizza where
they say hey it's good anytime or if
it's bad it's bad it's good whatever but
yeah Nick Cage he's a type of good actor
that you're like you see him be great
and you're like oh yeah yeah yeah he can
be amazing I mean he is you're right
Sushi's perfect and then Ghost Rider is
like you know the airport Sushi or
whatever that's I I gave money to the
wrong guy or something yeah yeah he had
some gambling stuff that guy
what so tell me about uh Philadelphia
well I don't want to jizz in my own hair
but it was probably the best comedy
weekend of in my life that CL that
doesn't shock me because you're
a prepping for something you're in a
locked in zone yep it's one of the best
clubs in the country I am my favorite
yeah it's your favorite it's my number
one number one now it is it was always
teetering in the top five but now it's
number one helium Philly because
um
I love everything about it let's go
through it we live in New York no flight
no flight yeah in the city I love it's
in the city it's like right in
Rittenhouse Square like yeah you walk
Pat you blink you walk past and then you
walk in it's just this giant Arena of
Comedy it's kind of like slightly
smaller Carolines too yes exactly
exactly the staff is great you know uh
they run it with an iron fist it's so
good got the Green Room goes right out
to the stage and Philly is a town much
like Boston
they don't tolerate pretension right and
that's what you need for good audiences
well it's a mix of of blue collar and
you know white collar which yeah it's a
harmonious mix right much how much like
how Boston has the MIT the Harvard they
also got the [ __ ] you know butcher
who's on uh fentanyl every night you
know hitting his wife do you need both
and you don't need him hitting his wife
I can't change uh science but you know
it's a very delicate recipe I need
spousal abuse for this to work it works
and and when I make a special abuse joke
they laugh at it because I go that's
like us you know and uh it just it just
that connection and that mix and that
gumbo and then I took the 1209 train
back on Sunday got it at three in the
morning that's the best time oh it's the
best of the best so late train ride's
kind of nice too yeah we're like man
people will say stuff like is it hard to
work late at night I'm kind of like is
it it's hard to work at rush hour oh
you're on the train with everybody
we get the piece we get the yeah I mean
look we get the other [ __ ] like if
there's construction they ain't waiting
for us yes no one respects it doesn't
matter if you work at night no one
respects a guy who wakes up at 11 A.M I
know I know you wake up at 11 like you
[ __ ] bum I know I was working late
exactly my job is I was drinking but I
was I was working too part of the job
you know kind of I'll tell you
but yeah you're right I mean I sleeped
in I slept in because I was still sick I
was getting over it and we were hitting
it hard every night doing shows and who
was opening for you I had Sean Murphy
who's murdering murdering this guy gets
no love he can't get accredited he's
getting love every week on this podcast
I hope so because this guy is weird
looking and gangly and uh hilarious just
such a great writer such a killer comic
and murdering every night where people
I'm getting messages is going who is
that opener who was that guy I was
pleasantly surprised that came out of
nowhere and I'm like I know he's a beast
nobody old people don't realize Like
Comics that don't bring a good opener
like look some places now flights are
absurd so we're not doing it everywhere
but like most of the time I'll bring
someone who is a murderer yeah because
it makes the whole show better if Comics
who like purposely bring someone who's
not that strong right you're doing a
disservice to your show and you're doing
a disservice to that crowd as well
completely complete and the host I
brought Umar Khan who's this he's like
the the big guy in Baltimore he's a cool
guy cool guy runs a couple shows knows
everything about comedy he knows how to
run a show he knows he's got a great act
so he kills up front then Murph dog
comes in and just [ __ ] hurricanes the
place and then I go out there and it was
just then we come in the group we all
talk about it and it was amazing and
we're working on our acts together and
it was just like a little lab in that
green room of of joke writing I love
that man it was really special and
Murphy doesn't drink so he's like the
perfect opener because he won't go he
won't be like let's get some hookers
come on what are we doing you know which
is always fun but uh he he's good
influence
you know you want a little bit of danger
but uh I don't want a little bit of
danger come on let's go to the donkey
show that is a hilarious the opener
who's doing blow and he's like come on
let's get some [ __ ] you're like dude
you [ __ ] you're opening you got to
settle down you gotta I know but you
know I eat like a little Ravel Rouse
every now and then I told you I was I we
watched rounders last week which like I
think is such a great movie it's funny
video
Max and you got you know Ed Nord and Ed
Norton's like my favorite actor really I
hear he's a [ __ ] that's what everybody
says I think that's why I like him it's
because he's such a perfectionist but
like growing up he was my favorite actor
because he was like he's a beast don't
get me wrong yeah I mean because he can
do everything you know you can play a
tough guy he can play like a whatever
you know Primal Fear yeah it's his first
role and then like debut American
History X like as a kid I was like this
is insane yeah uh rounders you know even
when he goes kind of lighter like
Keeping the Faith or like people versus
Larry Flynn he plays the lawyer he's
different in every movie great Point
great red uh what is it bruh Red Dawn
not Red Dawn red dragon red dragon we
never saw that one yeah it's not the
best but he's great is my point so the
Keaton one oh uh Birdman bird man he's
fun in that incredible yeah that was a
great movie oh super cool people [ __ ] on
that and I was like [ __ ] you I think it
won best picture or at least nominated
did It win best picture man what one it
was it it was in the running I'm pretty
sure anyway way my point is I brought a
rounder so it's like that shitty friend
it's like you've seen it in Mean Streets
you've seen in like pope of Greenwich
Village all those like great New York
movies there's another one and you know
our boy Brian koppelman and David Levine
wrote it they're like the coolest guys
too so it won it won it's a great movie
yeah but you know rounders that [ __ ]
the guy's name is worm I love it I know
because that's like every one of your
friends is like with a girlfriend it's
like come on worm yeah you don't [ __ ]
know him like I know him yep every guy
has a friend like that or you really do
you don't understand we have a history
worm turns out to be shitty but like the
point is yep you have friendships as a
as a adult man you have to explain to
people right right that's so true I kind
of feel like Biden feels like that about
his kid Hunter he's like it would blow
again Russia on a laptop what are you
doing oh and Trump about his kid yeah
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] yeah I'm Junior
exactly I mean that kid is Kendall from
succession for sure oh man dead on dead
but I mean just doing blow just like
tweet but uh yeah you had that kid
growing up did I have like I know that
kid yeah you had a worm and you're like
everyone did yeah
yeah everyone had that I mean I I still
have friends like that when I'm like
[ __ ] you know oh the jumping fences at
parties I had to do to get away from
fights because he would throw the
grandfather clock in the pool at the
house party he took one time my friend
took a [ __ ] they were these uh what do
you call like heaters on the floor like
grates and he took a [ __ ] in the great
and then he turned the heat on and it
was just the whole house smell I'm like
that's not a fun prank not a fun prank
but also pretty Innovative and kind of
clever you know like where you're like
you piece of [ __ ] we were I was making
out with that girl [ __ ] you but Richard
Pryor was Innovative that ain't
Innovative oh that takes a lot I don't
know can I do another can I try what he
had oh I mean this is killer it's killer
I just want to mix it up a little bit
why not I'll tell you good drink hell
yeah but yeah that my friend uh one time
he was like you know I've never really
been in a fist fight like my brother
beat the [ __ ] out of me and he went up
to a guy at a party goes do you want to
fight me and the guy was like no
so he's like let's just fight he pushed
him and he fell over and they fought now
my friend lost but
I I kind of respected that
yeah he just didn't like like I don't
respect it but I kind of there's
something
weirdly Charming about a guy zero [ __ ]
he gave no [ __ ] one time I and this is
the last thing I'll say bite me it's so
it's so funny he was the craziest guy
one time he I look over and somebody
goes can you fill my beer up and I was
like you want to ask him to fill your
beer up and he's like who's that I was
like all right it's your funeral and I
look over and he's feeling a bit and his
dick is in the glass while he's filling
the guy's beer up and I'm like wow there
he is that's my guy that's [ __ ] yeah
he was that guy it's like the guy on any
sport team where you're like you know
you hate him unless they're on your team
yes that's exactly like oh this dude's a
lot but but like everyone has a friend
they have to explain [ __ ] like it's
tough it gets tougher when you become an
adult and a friendship comes with an
explanation though I know when you're
just like where you're just like all
right this is Bob he's a degenerate
Gambler he uh he has a drinking problem
right he smokes crack occasionally
he's a habitual exactly you know well my
friend Adam man grew up with him like
total totally not I wonder if he even
listens to this but uh
you know Adam at a good heart he's one
of those kids same with my guy chess
champion whoa like as a child he was
ranked second in the [ __ ] country as
chess what he was one of those kids so
holy [ __ ] like there was interviews of
him as a child with a bow tie on TV he
interviewed now he had a messed up home
life so so then later on Adam is going
down some dark holes to get thrown out
of school you know
blowing lines like I've never seen it
smoking crack doing everything like
smart people are get [ __ ] up too
that's what he was he was smart yeah
this guy would be on crack hustling
dudes at [ __ ] Washington Square Park
he would go to the he'd go he'd be like
oh I don't know how to play chess let's
put some money on it and he would he
would destroy them because he was he's a
genius chess player I mean that's how he
made his living he would just tutor kids
in chess oh my God this is a movie yeah
he's a hustler he's an interesting kid
got a great heart but like [ __ ] man but
he'd always be in trouble yeah oh hell
yeah you're the man Dylan thank you he'd
always be in trouble
I mean she I remember he'd come to
anytime I'd be doing a casino gig he'd
just be there I just walk out and he'd
just be at the gig like I'd be in like
Foxwoods I'd be at like Atlantic City
he'd be like hey buddy and I'd be like
this is like out of a movie like you
didn't text me oh and you're also like
great to see it but also like oh man
this weekend it's a different it's a
different weekend it's a very different
week I was planning on writing this
weekend yeah now this dude's here I
remember this is one of the best ones I
could walk out this is a gig I never got
paid for either AC damn this
[ __ ] skipped town hate it hate
AC but I walked out I had a good time
there a few weeks ago though and
Amelia's new room it was pretty good uh
yeah Emilio's a good guy and that that
is a that's actually a solid room solid
room but I walk out and even Reno looks
at AC and he's like oh you got to get
your [ __ ] together when Reno is [ __ ]
on you you got to get it going it's so
dingy you know it's like having a guy
with no teeth be like you gotta clean up
your act you gotta start flossing man
yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] how about that paper
plane huh this is [ __ ] incredible not
too bad right came from Chicago in the
80s wow
this is insane so did John Candy
I don't know what that means but yeah
hey man I'll tell you uh he shows up so
he shows up the Gigan AC never get paid
for it it was one of those like dark I
remember like they put me in a condo
it's hilarious when you play in a decent
hotel and they're like we got a
different place for you to stay like I
can't even stay in the [ __ ] mediocre
hotel attached to the casino yeah show
them in some condo I remember I just
stumbled and drunk one night I see a
cockroach I stomp on it and then I just
fall right into the bed yeah I'm like
that's that was the week in a nutshell
anyway weekend I mean week working with
a great old school comic I was working
with uh
I won't say his name on everybody he's
an old school act you're middling no
it's a three-person oh okay so we just
all split time and he uh he's been
around forever he's telling me Seinfeld
stories he's telling me uh Carlin's
stories he knew he opened for Carlin for
half a year he toured Carlin really cool
guy and uh I remember he said he went up
to George Carlin trying to Buddy up to
him at some point and said uh man that
uh that dice what a [ __ ] hack or
something like that and he goes I think
it's good what he's doing that's what
Carlin said whoa he's making people
uncomfortable I like it whoa interesting
yeah yeah interesting anyway I walk out
from the gig and
like you know not great crowds
uh and I just see Adam at the at the
table he's playing poker at the table
and he's [ __ ] up a lot and he's and
he's drunk and he's trolling people at
the table he's like you [ __ ] he's
calling people [ __ ] fish because you
fish look at you you fish because you're
biting at everything kinda we gotta have
this guy on I love this guy Adam will be
good holy [ __ ] what is he doing now does
he have a job he's a chest he's a chest
Still Still chest wow you know I don't
know how to play chess which is sad oh
it's like a like I'm bad at it but it's
a cool game I think of course it's been
around for centuries and kings and
Sultans and all that [ __ ] people love it
I love I mean like I wish it was a game
I wish I was good at yeah it leads to so
I mean I watched the Bobby Fischer doc I
mean that kid's [ __ ] up yeah dude he's
a mess Jewish guy Brooklyn Dad ran out
mom was abusive yada yada he hated chess
he hated it he yada yada over the best
part
[Music]
but yeah you got to beat that Russians
that's what it was all about and there's
so much pressure and tell that to Simone
biles all right
apparently she was on a adderall and
they don't allow that in China really
that's what's going around now Adderall
is a good stuff man oh yeah you ever
take that stuff oh yeah but it's a
Gateway it's a gateway to what like says
well a little bit until you start
hitting the hard stuff really I think
you do a little lateral a lot of a lot
of guys I know doing Adderall if they
weren't prescribed they started doing
blow
yeah you need to keep that up I got some
of that stuff I'll take like whatever
like uh brand shittier version of that
stuff I'll get prescribed but yeah I uh
I'll take it I haven't taken in a while
but like man you get work you're
basically Bradley Cooper and Limitless
you are just laser focused yeah man you
know it's crazy I got a physical today
yeah yeah Netflix they making it a
physical which is silly I'm like I just
did eight hours in Philly and you're
like we gotta do we gotta do a half hour
here you sure you can handle it I'm like
what are you kidding podcast what do
they say it's classic I mean uh I had to
cough obviously but man it felt great
she's like how old are you I'm like 37
how tall like 5 10 How much do you weigh
I don't know 160. she did all my [ __ ]
blood pressure heart rate you know
whatever Ox ax she was like you are in
Tip Top you're you're lean you got this
you got that I was like yeah sounds like
the start of a porno I know she was like
a hot Jewish lady too yeah young Ashley
but uh I told her I can't sleep she's
like all right get some stuff here
you're good to go and so I got some
sleeping pills out of it really yeah so
thank you Ash I mean she might get fired
but uh she's clearly a quack but either
way I appreciate you that's great it's
fun never go see a doctor and you just
get another doctor like you make an
appointment with this hot shot doctor
yes we could never get away with that
you could never buy a ticket to see Mark
Norman and it's just some other guy
you're like yeah I recommend him right
he's he was under my tutelage yeah
exactly exactly that's so true no I I
was supposed to see some dude and she
walked in and I felt guilty because I
didn't want to be like where's the man
you know but I was like I thought I was
supposed to see Mr whatever and she was
like he's busy I'll take over and I was
like great women are great at everything
you know I smoothed it over but uh
she was she was super cool and great
it's fun being on that table when you're
like oh it's a it's good news you know
because you you're on that butcher paper
like you got a tumor you gotta Lance
this you got a you know uh assist but
it's nice when they're like ship shape
that is nice and then you're like all
the things I've done you sure the well
don't take [ __ ] fentanyl from a
stranger again oh yeah I didn't mention
that oh don't do it
not doing it that's that's freaked me
out man oh that was horrible horrible
sleeping in a hotel lobby for three
hours yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] I don't recommend it and then my
host was like oh I used to do four of
those a day I'm like Jesus Christ yeah
well that's why he's hosting you gotta
[ __ ] you gotta take care of yourself
man yeah we'll stick to the uh the
Grandpa's cuff
yeah give me another one yeah
you talked me into it oh turkey's not
too shabby huh The 100
what do you think thank you Dan
is that is that like low quality booze
or we thought it was great well turkey
is great it's just higher proof so you
got to be ready for it you know and you
have to soften it up with a few other
things so it's perfect for the paper
plane and you like you like it to be do
you like the taste the booze so that's
perfect a little bit Yeah Yeah I want to
know what's there because otherwise it's
going to be just like a nice little soft
soft little drink if it's 40 like you
know if it's four roses or Wizard or
anything like that but uh Wild Turkey
101 it'll get you there you know what a
taste of this to hear me out on this
because this is a leap
you know when you're going down on your
lady and there's a
Scent of a vagina I'm not talking fish
and uh Taco tuna whatever I'm talking
just a hint of normal human that's what
you want if it's completely smell I'll
go one further I'll go with full-on
human yeah you want some real stank I'm
not saying stank but I love the smell
this yeah the smell of the vagina that's
how I feel it's the same with booze I
want a little bit of stank I want you
your your natural lady here my go-to
drink is is a Manhattan mine is which is
a hard drink that's all alcohol yeah
exactly yeah I like tequila with a
squeeze of lime yeah so yeah we like we
like [ __ ] yeah sorry yeah dude we sound
like that one guy who's like clearly gay
he's like I love [ __ ] hey everybody
good to be here at the bar love [ __ ]
the guy who drinks 151 that guy's uh
he's like I eat ass yeah
I know right oh man that is tough when
the guy's like man how good is [ __ ] am
I right that friend you know that we've
seen that guy we know exactly who we're
talking about we're talking about the
same type of dude yeah the guy's like
man [ __ ] man
it's weird because like it's so open
like you'd be gay now nobody gives a
[ __ ] go be gay be trans be whatever bi
whatever you are but like back in the
day there must have been so many gay
dude like Mad Men there was that clearly
gay guy Salvatore right yeah who just
had you just had to like go with it he
had to get married and he just
disappeared from that show yeah
yeah that's crazy yeah man that was I
think back in the day like you want to
live that life I always loved that arc
on Mad Men where Don Draper like kind of
saw him and didn't really judge because
he's like who the [ __ ] am I I love that
I'm an adulterer yeah I made you like
this guy's [ __ ] around his wife it's
funny it's like that Code of Silence
like he's like yeah we're all shitty but
also Draper has his secret so he's like
you got yours I got mine what's a bodyco
that it's tough to watch like my
favorite shows like I have so many like
great favorite shows it's almost tough
to give a new show a chance because I
can just revisit my favorite shows you
know oh yeah I know I know that's true
definitely gotta watch this new Netflix
thing like it's original original
Netflix shows are usually not that good
HBO I just watched the undoing that's my
wreck for the week I gotta check this
dude it's so you just finished mayor of
East Town yes loved it the undoing is
[ __ ] strong all right it's Nicole
Kidman and Hugh Grant and they're both
they're both great and dude Donald
Sutherland just kills it wow he's still
going he's still going I love that guy
that guy rules yeah he's the reason
Animal House got made he's so funny in
that movie oh he's great he's great
great with his ass cheek cleavage with
the sweater when he's getting the best
perfect so perfect
sleeping with the professor come on
great movie I'm an Animal House guy over
Caddyshack which I know is wow I'm not I
love animals over caddy shot I love it
if you've got Dangerfield Ted Knight
Chevy Chase and Bill Murray and you're
going Animal House I like animal because
it's more of a film
which I know is crazy Caddyshack is like
it's sketches after it's [ __ ] Bill
Murray do it look it's great I love it
don't get me wrong I love Bill Murray
he's like one of my heroes but like
but it's in the hole like all that it's
just here's Bill Murray being funny
here's Rodney being funny here's Ted
Knight being hilarious here's Chevy
Chase being hilarious but it's a little
all over the place but as a film to me
Animal House is more cohesive you laugh
harder at animal house and do Caddyshack
I don't know about that I don't know
about that you probably called me jokes
thank you Ted Knight and [ __ ] and
Caddyshack oh he's the number one he's
the number one MVP for Dangerfield I
mean Dangerfield just walking in that
Country Club like inspired like that
like made me want to be a comedian I
know because he's just going through a
room of stiffs and insulting all of them
going up to that lady you must have been
something before electricity all right
they give you a free bowl of soup with
that hat yeah I mean it looks good on
you though I mean there's a million of
them but I don't know I just as a movie
Caddyshack like I like when a comedy is
also a good movie like Trading Places
great movie Coming to America great
movie
Anchorman is funny as hell but it's a
little whoopsy doozy sketches over yes
over like an actual film that's just a
personal pref what's silliness over
right yeah for sure right they're in a
fight with a trident like I love it it's
all over the top but it's like well now
I like a little reality all right
because I like pulling comedy out of
real [ __ ] that's why I like the Seinfeld
show or Larry David so much fair enough
but that's just me that's fair enough no
it's a stylistic preference yeah I get
that but hey I get I've gotten my ass
kicked or say it's good all right I'll
watch it well I gotta hear your take on
Rick and Morty now
oh [ __ ] you don't like it do you
oh where's the pilot because I don't
want to get too far into it because I'd
like to talk to you about it okay
it's pretty it's pretty great I love
like some of the jokes in it you're like
I've never seen a joke like that and I I
love that like when he goes shoot that
guy and he's like I don't want to hurt
anybody he's like no he doesn't have
feelings he's a he's a like a alien and
he shoots he goes I got kids you know
and the guy I love that I've never seen
a joke like that like he's a henchman I
love it and he's like I have kids what
are you doing you know and then he
evaporates or whatever
I don't love sci-fi just in general I
hate sci-fi I hate Star Trek I hate all
that [ __ ] so it's not really
my cup but I love the scientist guy I
love the the the [ __ ] relationship
with them too I love how he keeps
fighting to keep the kid there I love
it's great keep going but I'm gonna keep
going I'm in it only gets better it's so
good man uh it's not even about the
aliens in this the sound no no no it and
also like greatness transcends genre you
know like
good point good point okay Blade Runners
are great Noir it's not just a sci-fi
movie you know yeah all right all right
I'm only in the pilot by the way but it
was great at the end where he's like
Rick and morty.com yeah this was this
was fun remember if you want to see more
Rick and morty.com like the the the
scientists keeps saying that is that
Rick Rick yeah yeah so great the burping
the alcohol it's fun it's great man I
love it I love I'm in but I'm only in
one app give me a peeve oh I gotta pee
for you peeve me now this is a weird out
of left field peeve all right you never
hear about right field why is it always
left you know what I mean not right it
feels right Field's actually harder yeah
that came right out of right field maybe
because it's right out of right you
don't want the double right yeah but at
a left field left field is not as far
the guy with the better arm is playing
in right field right came right out of
left field as a kid shitty player plays
right field but when you're in the major
leagues you need to have a [ __ ] gun
exactly weirdo it's left field only that
came uh that came just at a right feel
why can't we say that I don't know and
they also say kiss my left testicle it's
always the left I have my left nut yeah
my left nut he always here left nut suck
my left nut
never the right unless it's Lance
Armstrong
then he just says suck my nuts suck my
nut I remember when I first heard he had
testicle kit was it ball cancer
testicular cancer and then Cheryl Crow
got breast cancer and some kid at school
was like he must have [ __ ] on her tits
I was like that's the funniest smartest
thing I've ever heard in my life you are
for now the king of comedy wow I mean
that blew my mind as a kid I was like
that is comedy yeah I don't know I was
probably like 31.
how long ago was that did you see the
documentary on Lance oh I loved it
incredible I loved it and just to double
down on that Bill Burr defended Lance
Armstrong on Conan on panel Lance
Armstrong called him he did his pod
they'd talk about the whole thing and he
gets it all out it's great wow yeah Bill
Burr's like they were on drugs you were
on drugs he's like exactly we were all
on drugs why did I get popped and they
kept all the money I made them because
no one gives a [ __ ] about the people
that failed Andre yeah exactly you care
about the people who went on drugs you
know what I mean like performance
dancing drugs if they're not helping
your performance
then who gives a [ __ ] right right like
if we do steroids no one gives a [ __ ]
because we're still gonna suck yeah good
point 1996 okay so I was 10 years old
well no wait 13 years old perfect man
um thank you the fact that he just kind
of owns what a dick he is and I I
appreciate the honesty I mean he doesn't
seem like he was a great dude but you
know what
he was kind of a bad he was kind of a
badass total badass I feel like Kobe was
like that he's like I know I'm not very
nice on the court but he got nice by the
end though he got nice by the end but he
was also like get out of my way I'm I'm
winning Lance Armstrong man he really
there's something so badass about
cycling at that level I know because
it's so [ __ ] scary like you wipe it I
wipe out in a bike it sucks we're gonna
go can you imagine how much it sucks to
be going like that fast I never thought
about it it's scary dude and you ain't
wearing Pat you're wearing that [ __ ]
yoga pants shorts and the tight tight
shirt and a dress like you're delivering
[ __ ] UPS yeah how many of those what
is with older men and those [ __ ] skin
tight suits and those shoes and they
love cycling what is that
I have no desire to it's like 60 year
old 55 year old guys usually like rich
white guys who just cycle and they go
fast it looks awful I know then they
have to pop into Starbucks halfway and
they look like weirdos you know they're
like some kind of like they've been rock
climbing or something I can't ride a
bike what I I mean I I've done it I'm
just not good at it
exactly even have a dad no my dad
[ __ ] I talked to him about this the
other day I have a dad he [ __ ]
he gave me [ __ ] about the other day I
was like you never taught me dude really
we got to do a patreon episode I mean
you're gonna ride a bike we're going to
Central Park really we're gonna get a
mountain bike and I'm gonna teach you
we're gonna film the whole thing I'll
get in a city bike oh perfect right and
we'll do it in the grass if you fall
over no training wheels we'll get you a
helmet and you get a helmet oh all right
perfect got your special needs helmet
put it on we'll we'll do the whole thing
you know I yeah he was making fun of me
the other day he's like you can't ride a
bike I'm like you're my dad you're
making fun of me for this that's
hilarious oh guess what I I had to learn
to shave on my own too my dad told me to
shave when I was like seven and I'm like
I don't I'm not gonna retain this right
right exactly now I'm just cutting my
face up but I remember I did a show uh
on MSG like this was not the show I had
but this was like when Giannis and
Krista Stefano had a show on MSG called
the bracket I don't even know they have
that so they had a show where we'd be
like Talking Heads and I was one of the
talking heads and MSG is you know a
local sports network so they don't have
a big budget so yeah they're like oh
you're gonna be on every episode of the
season but you just show up and you
shoot all in one day I was like fine
I'll show up I don't know how to [ __ ]
shave I'm an adult man really yeah I
figured it out like [ __ ] I mean it's
pretty simple three years of cream on
you yeah but I would but I didn't I
wasn't gentle just like do it all at
once I would break out yeah so remember
I did a [ __ ] whole season of that
show and I would just have red marks all
over my they don't have a makeup
all over my neck so it'd be on in every
bar in the city it's MSG so every time I
just look up and I just see red all over
my neck and I'm like oh this is
disgusting ah and every TV tape it just
blights right on your face so the red
really pops brutal damn that's uh now we
gotta pull those up I want to see the uh
I don't know type in MSG red bumps Jew I
bet it pops up
but wait my peeve we we uh we got off on
a tear there
yeah
this goes back to my childhood I [ __ ]
hate
hate
lamps wow I hate when you go in a room
and there's no overhead light or wall
light or Mount it's all lamps okay well
you don't hate lamps exclusives they're
the [ __ ] star player yes exactly my
dad had a he loved lamp so it was all
you know my dad thinks he's some kind of
he fancies himself like a feng shui
architectural [ __ ] guzzling you know like
room designer interior guy and he was
like here's my lamp over here and I got
a lamp over there and he would he would
meticulously like put one on to like
light up a a painting and all that and I
hate it give me some light it like
depresses you lamb should be like Willem
Dafoe if they're carrying the whole
thing we got a problem if they're the
second or third
we got a nice little thing going oh boy
wow how did you that was the best
analogy I've ever heard you pulled that
out of your ass in two seconds yeah that
was great I'm with you Lambs are great
but if they're carrying the whole
[ __ ] room especially with the big
room it's dim it's dull it's it's a
bummer it's just sifting around in this
like Moody light ah I'm an
eight-year-old I want to have fun and
then go play and wanted to play video
games and it's like turn the [ __ ]
light on dad what are you doing he's
reading under a lamp with a pipe I'm
like you're not an intellectual shut up
you're drunk you're dead Sherlock Holmes
I know right exactly gotta drive me
crazy give me a goddamn I love his walk
in the room hitting the switch Boom full
lit up illumination baby give me Thomas
Edison and and Ben Franklin the lamp
paint the lamp the lamp is a is it
should not be carrying the whole team no
and also we had so many very like
antique and and like artsy lamps so you
got to get under there it's like an
upskirt and sometimes you're like on the
floor trying to find the [ __ ] you know
with that little weird nozzle thing and
you're on the wire and then sometimes
it's around the base like ah give me the
give me the clicker give me the full
switch I like a switch how about when
you go back and forth and it doesn't
turn on oh that's disappointing oh man
it is kind of like if you're fingering
someone and they just won't come you're
like I'm doing everything here what the
hell I'm hitting the button here yeah
that is a bummer so yeah that is my peep
I hate I had a hotel room in Philly the
Sonesta and it was just lamps so Nest is
a nice hotel great hotel but I open all
the curtains so you get the daylight but
once that you know Sunset hits it's all
lamp time and I had to get out of there
yeah the childhood
yeah a hotel it's I guess it depends on
the city because some of these cities
have tiny ass hotels what city are you
doing Philly that's a probably a small
room though right it was a solid room I
mean I don't need much but uh I like
just walk in Hit the Light you know
because also I'm paranoid about the
burglars and weird I got a real weird
phobias with all that going to the uh
shower and pull this oh every night even
at my own house I live in a big
apartment building with you know many
units and I'm like bear in mind I know
it and I look under the bed I do all
that [ __ ] you look under the bed I look
in the closets I'm scared damn I mean
I've walked in on multiple burglaries so
many burglaries have you walked in on I
don't know two eight or nine eight or
nine oh yeah and that's just the ones I
walked in on
sometimes you see a door and you see a
guy run out and you're like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I saw a guy run through my yard
once holding a computer monitor once
when I was a kid and I was like damn
damn yeah yeah you see that cord
dangling in the wind I don't have any
stores except once this is nothing but I
I walk back to I was living on like
108th and I uh
I walk in I guess I had a faulty fire
alarm someone called the called the you
know fire department on me you just like
break your door in and knock everything
over to turn it off I'm like I feel like
you guys got excessive I feel like they
just started like knocking [ __ ] I was
like [ __ ] you you wasted our time yeah
yeah I know they want to break some [ __ ]
after a while they just sit at home and
or they sit in that station it's like a
dump on one of my desks this was
excessive
exactly yeah I mean I got I got broken
into in the village about two years ago
yeah you told me that yeah came in
through the window I mean it was like a
caper climbed the fire skate came into
the window and it got it like triggered
me and you know the girlfriend grew up
in The Burbs and Cape Cod she's like wow
that's crazy I'm like I was sitting on
the bed like he was right here I felt so
uh what do you call it violated
Violet he took all my cash she was in my
drawer he see he put his finger his
Footprints are on my bed you really you
it definitely had too much cash in your
apartment oh yes how many thousands six
six Grandy's he took six grand but he
didn't touch anything else because he
took the cash did you almost respect how
he swooped him through your window a
little bit yeah and I part of me is like
did he know my schedule you know was he
like oh is it New York comedy club
tonight then he's at the cellar you know
like because he knew we were both not
home it was almost premeditated it felt
like an inside job but it wasn't they
caught the guy they got him they got him
you didn't get your money back it's
called Cash
I could just say oh he took a million
get it give it back you know like how
could they know
you take a laptop that's serious
I guess they put him in jail because he
robbed another guy that's how they
caught him but how do you know it was
him fingerprints we dusted damn yeah so
I'm sure he's out now that was a couple
years ago yeah it's like petty crime I
guess yeah I don't know but
yeah your brain you know when you get
when you get robbed your brain goes to
weird plate like I'm walking around the
neighborhood after that I'm like was it
him was it him was it him you know you
never know you never trust anybody again
exactly my bike got stuck you're in a
doorman building now no I hate a doorman
why I don't like the hello
but I don't like him out of the robbery
maybe but I got a good Lobby I gotta I
got him on a good Lobby yeah no one's
ever penetrated a good Lobby before I
just I love that I got a good that's the
dumbest [ __ ] I've ever I got a mezzanine
you got to get through one door then you
gotta do another door and then you don't
know what unit I'm in no criminals ever
penetrated glass
upset you could get into my building but
I was on the first floor of my old
building so I was the first basically
the first door and I was on the uh the
fire escape
ah jeez I know it it's crazy but yeah
you can't I mean I hate to say you don't
you don't want a first floor apartment
in New York no you really don't I hate
to say it but it's tough I'm taking you
know my girlfriend around today and
we're and we're just walking through and
it's like she's not from here so it's
like yeah every time I take the train I
see a crazy guy I'm just like kind of
trying to get her to not see it yeah the
guy's just like staring at me I'm like
uh I'm like kind of like I know what it
is he's just staring at me but she's
right there and I'm just like looking at
him back like stop looking at me dude
staring right at me and I'm just like
God damn it he's just still staring at
me I'm like hey let's just walk this way
for a second yeah you guys are walking
toward me like this I'm like [ __ ] and
then finally something else caught his
attention like thank God I'm like I
don't care if he [ __ ] with me but like
does he have to do it while she's there
I know it's like a kid you want to
protect you want to like not hurt you
don't want her to see horrible things
like a jerking off or a puking or
[ __ ] for sure I mean I want to do a
bit about it how it's like you want
someone to move here and that turns into
like
it's almost like a room New York is like
a roommate that you're like just behave
yeah that's great
then some dude comes down the train with
his dick out you're like you promised
come on why that's great that's a great
bid this paper plan is [ __ ] good how
have I never heard of this drink this
should be more popular
you know it's uh getting more popular uh
everybody loves aperol and this is like
one of the better ways to drink aperol
than an apple spirit so I would say hey
I agree an aperol Spritz feels a little
lady-ish if I might say so and I feel
like this paper plane what a great name
this is better than any Spirit flight
I've ever had get it spirit all right
all right that's 20 21 drink what do you
want hell yeah with an up cocktail [ __ ]
that you got that right I love it and
also I mean Michelle wolf popularized
the aperol Spritz of the comedy seller
then you're right there were nights when
we'd all be getting hammered on aperol
spritzes and Ari shafir would be
drinking though oh yeah the comics would
be drinking those and like [ __ ] man I'm
not gonna lie they [ __ ] hit well they
hit well and they're not too sweet they
got a little Tang they're really good
and they're spritzy they're like
effervescent you know wolves
it does it does
right that's why the uh those Housewives
really hit that [ __ ] hard you know
because they are miserable oh yeah one
of them was married to Kelsey Grammer
wow he was a drunk yeah dude well he was
[ __ ] doing everything I mean he's a
talent that guy that guy rules he's
great he's a great guy I love seeing him
on uh on Colbert and Colbert you know
he's prying because it was years ago
when Trump was running in like 2016
whatever maybe 2015. and he's like who
are you uh who are you gonna vote for
he's just crying because he knows he's a
Republican and he's like well my support
is behind Dr Ben Carson
just that Frasier voice that's great he
just killed me I was like this is
perfect I mean has that been done well I
guess I shouldn't say but a spin-off
from kind of a nobody character not a
Nobody But like a third string character
on cheers to the huge successful leading
role of a sitcom it's crazy I mean crazy
I know they tried to do that [ __ ] with
Joey but it's like yeah exactly exactly
Frazier is like next level it's crazy
how
he was [ __ ] up for like Seasons I know
I know and he pulled it off
isn't that crazy my friend just said
that uh Dave Chappelle he runs a club
Andrew Youngblood runs this great club
called the secret group in Houston and
he said Chappelle popped in one night so
he's like oh [ __ ] we gotta we gotta we
gotta go nuts we gotta tweet it out it
sells out in two seconds
I don't know if I should say this [ __ ]
but he said he was Chappelle was
hammered and like
ah [ __ ] it just you're too deep I'm too
deep and it's not that bad but he was so
J you know he's like legless and he was
so drunk he kept almost he was doing his
act he did like an hour or two he's
doing his that and he couldn't light the
cigarette because he was too drunk but
he said every joke would was Pitch
Perfect delivery Crystal Clear boom but
then he was like
wow for an hour he never lit it and but
yet he was so shit-faced but he was
perfectly killing and I'm like that's
what Frazier could do or Kelsey Grammer
yeah man I mean you'd see episodes of
that and and the physical comedy out of
all those actors that's one of the best
cast shows of all time and uh
even the dog was good it's incredible I
told you I went to a live taping what
yeah I was a kid my dad did like a fan
my dad a business trip to California so
he just like kind of turned into a
family vacation whoa and we went to uh
we got to go to a uh like a run-through
of a Frasier episode so we were like 10.
I was young I didn't I knew it was cool
like I was like it was crazy to watch
you know I think it was right when he
had the drug rumors so it was like
people knew he was struggling wow but he
was incredible I mean there was like one
scene where I think he forgot his lines
he was like I'm just like you know he
was like jittery but when he came in and
delivered you're like this guy's in on
another level really yeah he's like a
Phenom and what a great I mean my
parents kind of suck so like that's such
a great thing to show your kid you know
like oh we're going to the Tar Pits or
Disney World [ __ ] that we're going to
Frasier taping now my parents had a huge
influence on me wanting to pursue comedy
I think like [ __ ] like that and just
like when you come from a family of
lawyers it's just like there's a very
succinct way of speaking Yeah like my
brother sister and Dad all speak in a
very kind of uh
they don't waste words yeah they speak
in a very economical way so right yeah
so I think that definitely like
influences you're like wow they they're
good at just speaking that's part of
being a lawyer yeah wow man and they're
good at forming arguments I mean that's
like law being a lawyer in a lot of ways
similar to stand up totally similar
totally think of how many Comics we love
we're lawyers uh Geraldo Dimitri Martin
Alabama was he a lawyer yeah I don't
even know really yeah wow oh man imagine
that guy being your lawyer I'll tell you
higher higher Dangerfield yeah that's
true uh I feel like we got to do a we
didn't get your peeve I got a few I run
out of time here I got a few uh-oh one
is punctuality sure like when people
aren't punctual rather just people
getting ready you know uh I get it uh we
get it with this little lady thing sure
okay I and I'm very respectful of it I
get it but like I think you know women
just take longer to get ready the hair
the makeup the outfit
and and look they will be upset like I
literally will go I look I recorded the
last episode in shorts I get it I get it
too look at that we're wearing jeans and
a t-shirt it you know we don't we don't
put a lot of effort being a woman yeah
for sure women but they do take longer
of course and we're part of the same
team when we go out so I'm gonna notice
the part of the team that takes a little
longer like if there was a basketball
team and one guy's like let's [ __ ] go
and the other guy's like I'm not ready
yet
yeah Louie had that great bit he's like
I'm sorry I know Mike I shouldn't be
mean to my kid but if there's someone in
a group who doesn't put their shoes on
that kid's an [ __ ] you know I'm
butchering the joke but it's a good
point like kids are [ __ ] Louie's got
some of the best bits of all time of
course of course but so so yeah puncture
I'm with you my girl does that and I
think I brought it up before she goes
I'm like all right I'm going out to
whatever get get get deliver a packet
I'll I'll leave with you I gotta leave
too we'll leave together I'm like okay
let's go and she's like well wait hold
on then she has to bake a turkey do the
crossword puzzle and uh backflips yeah
yeah exactly I'm like I would have been
done by now but you you want to leave
together whatever that is the other
thing is my girlfriend can't drink
caffeine so I'm very well yeah it's just
like certain like Health stuff and
caffeine so I'm very like look
admittedly I'm more awake during the day
if I think about caffeine I'd be a
[ __ ] nightmare you drink enough
caffeine for the both of you dude I
drink
I'll I'll do four or five cups easy oh
yeah did you have an ulcer did you ever
get rid of that or is that still I'm all
right I think all right good oh [ __ ] I'm
even an ulcer at 28. you were like a
like a detective I was on tour with
Schumer yeah we were in Canada and I
went to the hospital and she was just
like she was like you didn't tell me you
went to the hospital and I was like I
don't want to buy I don't want to bother
her I feel the same way it's
embarrassing I was embarrassed by it
yeah she's taking us to these [ __ ]
fancy restaurants of course and I'm like
I'll have the uh I'll have the grilled
chicken yeah
yeah yeah what is that that's just
stinging in this just like holes in your
stomach leg it was just like yeah I
remember the doctor with a guy in like a
in pink pants and he was like he's like
yeah you're [ __ ] up he's like a French
Canadian guy just mocking me just
laughing I was like can I have orange
juice can I have any joy and he was just
like he was like nah ah at least it was
free
no I I mean no your health care doesn't
cover it doesn't Oh I thought it was
just free in Canada like you think you
just go to a doctor and they're like
yeah you don't this doesn't cause
anything yeah that's what I really
thought are you [ __ ] kidding me well
it's all paid for by the government I
thought right I mean that's what
Healthcare is is it not what are we what
are we fighting for are you [ __ ]
kidding me if you're Canadian you have
free healthcare but if you but if you're
an American visiting Canada they're not
just like you're a visitor we will also
give you I just figured it was a
hospital how do the doctors make money
well when you go get free coffee at a
hotel and you're An American in Canada
at a hotel you still get the coffee what
do you think I'm a Holiday Inn doctor
that's what I am I went to medical
school at La Quinta University
I'm just saying I thought it was free
I what you gotta be uh part of the
country have you ever heard any of this
[ __ ]
go to like uh the UK they will give you
any medical care I don't know about it
Canada okay okay so that's what I
thought it was the same show you know
there's some guy in an Alleyway he's
like yeah you got to pay for this yeah
you got a true dude
I did wear black face for some reason he
said it was part of the Cure I don't
know it was brown but yeah I thought I
really thought like oh it's a hospital
just you go in you go it's like a post
office or or not a post office like the
DMV that's free right what's free
something's free huh covet tests are
free some places yeah I got a free one
last week yeah but you got it they they
probably paid
who Netflix Oh no I went in if you do a
rapid test it's free the vaccine is free
the vaccine is free that's free okay
okay but people still don't want people
don't trust free if the vaccine were
five dollars oh people would take the
vaccine oh it's like a comedy show yeah
pay one dollar you'll you'll be more
invested if the vaccine if you make the
vaccine 4.99 it'll sell out you have to
create some sort of demand yes if you go
to a comedy show and it's free you're
like this show sucks if you go and it's
[ __ ] twenty dollars yep I'm all in so
true Make That vaccine [ __ ] it make it
9.99 yeah and then we'll like we'll give
you the second one for half off or
something exactly yeah you're gonna
think you get a deal
sorry the phlegm the booze I think is
breaking it up a little which is nice I
don't I don't know I think I think that
may work for one I don't know for two if
it's all right I'll stop it I want you
to be all right for your taping here I
don't want to be a negative influence
but good peeve good peeve I'm with you
100 and and what's cool about my girl is
she gets it and she's aware of it no she
gets it too I'm just saying punctuality
for me is big like I was on time here
tonight but I'm never [ __ ] early
enough because you're always 10 minutes
earlier well I like to get here and do
pull-ups and I don't want you to catch
me so you really do important
and then I come in and I say hello to
Matt and you know we talk about
something [ __ ] P90X team before this
show well I don't even go I don't go to
the gym so I used to go to the gym twice
a week regiment and it was like a big
part of my life and I feel like it makes
you healthier why don't you go anymore
my gym is closed because of covet which
is the Rec Center rec center me too yeah
I hate it I swim laps is what I do I'm
not a big weights guy I like swimming's
the best
great nothing better than swimming
that's why I love going to La you know I
you know I will never live there but
like I'll visit my girl in L.A and her
building's got a pool and I just I just
bang out some laps yeah mental health oh
yeah you feel good every muscle I make
some small talk with the old women who
also swim with me doesn't make you feel
amazing about your workout that the
woman next to me is 73 she's doing the
same thing but you know you both have
the same back problems but yeah you know
swimming is good my my friend is a
personal trainer he said the best best
exercise take a guess swimming walking
walking best exercise why is that that's
what I said I was like walking what are
you crazy low impact with swimming's low
impact true swimming's good too but he I
guess we're not always in a pool but
you're always walking you can just
anybody can walk if you don't have
access to pool you can still walk so get
out there and walk people yeah and
nothing better than a good walk well
that's the thing about this pandemic too
it's like people got to get in shape you
know oh yeah and who are we the [ __ ] to
give Health advice we're both drunk on a
podcast right now but I'm just saying
you know walk a little get you know take
care of yourself we don't want you guys
dying out there I know I mean fat is the
biggest coveted killer everybody's like
we got to do this but I was like well
how about you lose some weight there uh
sloppy jalopy get a vaccine so we can
[ __ ] tour and throughout the winter
please yes yes comedy's hot right now
all right you got a bit I feel like
we're going live I got a bit but uh you
know it's uh
here's an idea of it here but I need
something here tell me what you think so
I have a bit about aliens that's doing
pretty well I have a bit about you know
I was listening this podcast about
aliens and uh
illegal or space no space okay what
about UFOs and stuff and uh one of the
things they said was like you know if
they land here they're far ahead of us
you know in terms of their technology so
we should be worried right but I was
thinking about it you know
aliens you know if they land here what
if they land here and they're like five
years ahead of us because everyone's
like they come bearing gifts what if
they're like yeah you watch sports on
your internet well yeah like we can make
that like you know we can make that
slightly faster uh that's all they got
they're like we can make your internet
like a little faster that's that's what
we're at that's funny but there's a
little we can help and they're just like
that's it like yeah that's what we got
we can like if you watch on Hulu we can
make it like up to like you know regular
cable right I like that I like it it got
a pretty good it got a pretty good laugh
at uh you know in Long Island yeah like
we know how to really make you we know
how uh to stop baldness that's it that's
all you got like well yeah you guys
can't do that [ __ ] you we got a good we
got a good add pill yeah we uh do you
guys have a depression problem we got
like Zoloft uh 2.0 yeah that's not a
cure it's another tree exactly I like
that I like that a lot that's good
they're like have you guys heard about
CBD we're like yes we know what they're
like all right all right never mind
the [ __ ] they give us right like you
guys do wet wipes yet yeah we got wet
wipes oh [ __ ] we thought we had yeah do
you wipe your ass with those nah I can't
do it why not I don't know I don't feel
like I deserve it
really I never could buy a wet way but I
get the roll I move on with my life it's
a it's an insane notion to have just a
dry paper towel wiping your ass but I'm
I'm too deep in if you buy a new place
would you get a bidet yes really I would
get a bidet because bidets used to be
like
you know that oh Elvis has a bidet you
know but now it's like everybody's got a
bidet I go to open Michael's house they
got a bidet really oh yeah it's like a
200 Monica who's open micro I'm telling
you people do you buy it you stick it on
the on the seat of your toilet and you
like it you hook up two pipes you're
done do you like it that's great yeah
and I've had some rough stuff in the
back door really well we've all had a
few skid marks let's be honest let's be
real yeah yeah I definitely had
um
yeah I've definitely had I'm in love man
I was down in Pepto like a job yesterday
I had to leave that I literally had to
leave the house for Pepto that was bro I
was looking at it you went on like an
AAA rant like look man I was having a
tough week I did crack once I blew a guy
but you're talking about Pepto it was my
ass well that was his
but yeah yeah I mean bidet will I think
a bidet will be standard in 10 years in
a house yeah they're kind of nice right
yeah oh yeah you know a lot of houses
you go like they already have filtered
water amazing homophobia is slowing down
the movement on that ah like maybe which
it makes no sense you'll stick a finger
in your ass but you won't take some
water yeah and it's hygiene it has
nothing to do with sex and it feels good
it is hygiene and and guess what it's
probably spreading much less bacteria
and [ __ ] to your partner I mean I'm
all for the bidet if we knew you know
they always do that test every 100 year
or every 50 years hey if you knew what
was on this Subway pole you know but
semen it's feces it's saliva it's all
this [ __ ] if you knew what was in your
underwear
I think you would
vomit uncontrollably for three hours is
that a good time to give our plug to
this week's sponsor yes
sheath underwear folks swearing it right
now look at that I'm wearing it too look
at that hey there you go we gave
ourselves a Melvin that's what they call
in the front Melvin I haven't said that
word in 20 years a [ __ ] nerd name
it's a great never name your kid Melvin
no bad name bad that's a rough one that
kid's game if that kid doesn't get the
[ __ ] kicked out of him then he has just
become such he's surpassed expectations
oh yeah keeps your balls off your leg
there's two pouches one for your dong
one for your sack keep the ammo separate
from the gun it's super supportive they
look good they feel good they're like
stretchy and silky at the same time the
lady likes them she's like you look
great in that look at these These are
camo like weird camels dude I have those
at home too I would never buy these but
when I put them on I feel cool as hell
your dick was in the Gulf War I love it
yeah I got a Sandy Hook or no wait Sandy
dick [ __ ] oh the hook what the [ __ ] this
is the plug man I'm sorry this guy was
in the Iraq War by the way this guy's a
badass oh yeah he's a veteran supportive
veteran this guy's a a great he's a
great dude yeah he's a veteran he loves
Comics which is why he's on this podcast
uh go to sheathunderwear.com and order
with promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order and sheath underwears 100
back money back guarantee that
sheathunderwear.com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls they really are great I wear
them every day I don't even go I see the
other underwear in the in the drawer and
I don't even touch them I'll say this
too I have under other underwear and my
girlfriend is bummed when I'm not
wearing shoes she thinks this just looks
good she thinks I think it's got like a
classy look it does and it's got a good
fit and she's like least feel nice why
would you want to wear these so
literally we got the laundry yesterday
and she's like you should always be
wearing these they're good underwear
that is from a [ __ ] lady guys
if you're a Melvin out there
a lady might be [ __ ] you know
intrigued yeah yeah they look good they
look like you you made an attempt like
you can't you made an effort you look
like you're kind of you just rock this
and you got no shirt on no pants you
look like a CEO in undies yeah that's
good I bet this is what Epstein rocked
ah well easy that doesn't help the brand
all right I did it too far but he was a
millionaire so that was rich I was just
going for the money thing yeah he did
some other bad stuff too that was a
horrible joke I ripped on stage I go hey
look everybody's mad at Bezos for going
to space I'm like look at least he's a
billionaire who did good [ __ ] well I did
a really similar bit this weekend that's
[ __ ] hilarious I'm sure mine
punchline is worse than yours it was
super cheesy but it killed I said uh
look Epstein gets a million dollars like
I want a [ __ ] a 14 year old in the ass
and Jeff Bezos gets a billion dollars
he's like I just want to go to Uranus
killed Guild I'll never do it again but
it was a riff and it just that's good it
leveled because
I did a thing about Bill Clinton it
wouldn't have been on the on you know
it's a better Mission because Bill
Clinton wasn't on it oh there you go
that was my angle yeah yeah because the
Lolita or whatever yeah yeah that was my
angle on the line yeah who wasn't on
that fight like Chelsea Handler they
said was on that I heard that yeah it's
like who was it on that [ __ ] plane
yeah dear white people
[Laughter]
Chelsea privilege we never talk about
like just pretty privilege oh it's the
number one yeah good looking is the
number I'd rather be a hot black guy
than an ugly white guy for sure oh yeah
oh yeah good looking is number one good
looking's good yeah yeah I mean I treat
good-looking people but I've noticed I
caught myself doing it what do you do
you know you're just like oh hey how are
you Dan's here if Dan was a a hideous
guy with one tooth and an eye patch I'd
be like hit the bricks this dude is
pulling so many numbers while he's
bartending it's not it was crazy they
were good comments like Dan's cute he's
cute and you're like he's just Tall come
on if that guy was five one you wouldn't
be batting an eye but tall is good Dan
definitely he would [ __ ] [ __ ] up though
I think like if we were at War you and I
would be dead in a second and Dan would
be [ __ ] still like I know he'd be
shooting [ __ ] dead I could see
you with a bazooka on your shoulder like
go go I gotcha you know with the
backpack on and like call that [ __ ] even
if this was a war with a bayonet he'd be
stabbing dudes would be [ __ ] laying
down just dead
he'd be carrying the team I could see
that yeah you got you you got like uh
put your troop on your shoulder and run
keep running Vibes you know that's like
my whole name you know Daniel Victoria
reporter for Duty you know whoa what's
your ethnic background I'm Russian oh
yeah are you Russian I'm like a
Sephardic Jew so Eastern European damn
I've got some Russian if we're doing 23
me I've got some Russian all right all
right well some Russian uh DNA in there
don't worry I'll carry both of you guys
under my back it's all good yeah
dude the Russians are the baddest
[ __ ] oh scariest no one like
the Russians nobody like I don't know if
khabib is that Russian I don't know what
you would call it khabib is Russian he's
in that area he's in that wheelhouse no
he's uh he's uh I believe he's a Kazakh
he's he's like from uh the southern
satellites
oh I wasn't battle the Bulge like and
that's like a big problem they don't
like to be called oh [ __ ] sorry khabib
don't hurt I didn't know he did not
strike me as Russian but uh Man Battle
of the Bulge was it was that the one
with the Russians just lost like [ __ ]
everyone and they were is that am I
right on this one well they just would
not give in it was like it was that was
like that's just not being tough that's
like Russians are a combination of tough
as [ __ ] but also the most stubborn human
being oh yeah and they they got nothing
to lose they're like let's go all in
I'll die on this hill I think that was
uh uh you remember that movie uh Enemy
at the gates yes yeah that's that's
that's that's that movie like they were
just like listen like you go in front
you get a gun and then the guy behind
you gets just like the clip so when the
guy in front of you dies you take his
gun and you put your clip in and you
keep going they just threw bodies in
until you know around them Rachel Vice
man she was the hottest oh so hot lady
how about uh getting Loud by Daniel
Craig
in real life yeah they date we should
say they date well they they're better I
think they're together
married I think they're married right I
think they're together they she's great
I love Rachel Vice oh yeah and uh that
movie man I remember we saw on a school
trip for some reason I don't know why we
sound like a school trip but they're
like this is a history movie and right
when they bust out that scene where
she's jerking off Jude Law I was like
yeah yes
that was exciting as a kid yeah oh
anytime I went and saw species with my
friend and his mom and I'm like oh it's
a sci-fi movie it'll be fun and the
whole thing is just Natasha entrance
[ __ ] dudes and then killing him and
I'm like this is unbelievable she's got
a huge tit she's hot as hell oh my God
pull up a photo of Natasha I mean is
there a hotter woman on the planet than
her she was hot oh my God that movie
looked like a steaming pilot it was
horseshit Michael madsen's in it it's a
pile of dog [ __ ] on Wheels man Michael
Madsen on Jim and Sam when he's just
like yeah holy [ __ ] ah come on I mean
that's like made in a lab type [ __ ] what
nude Michael Madsen was like talking to
Norton and Sam Roberts and he was like
just talking about like talking about
like hitting a woman and he was like oh
come on you've met a woman they're like
no we most certainly have wow hey come
on we're we're eating here but uh trying
to perform showing his tits but he was
like he's like you've met a woman they
were like no wait of course we have and
he's like oh come on and they were just
like no we haven't done it he's like
yeah okay he wouldn't take that and
we're like
that's great it's pretty that's pretty
I think I mean it's pretty that's great
because that's what you want when you
you interview Michael Madsen you want
all of that and then he delivers a
little for sure I mean I don't want to
anybody hit a woman but I'm saying if
you got an interview he's famous for
cutting a guy's ear off in a movie right
yeah yeah which he improvised no yeah
that'd be a hell of a prosthetic
well uh we should tell everyone make
sure to sign up for the patreon at
patreon.com we might be drunk pod uh
email so we might be drunkpod.com we
might be drunk at gmail wait we might be
drunkpod at gmail sorry I've had a few
yeah we might be drunkpod gmail.com Oh
yeah follow our socials you know we got
Mark and myself on all the same [ __ ]
they got we might be drunk uh
on Instagram yeah or so we might be
drunk proud
well that's a good question don't type
it we might be sure you'll find it on
Instagram give it a go see us on the
road I'm in uh Kansas City Missouri this
weekend then Portland Oregon nice then
uh Royal Oak Michigan Boston
Massachusetts uh Atlanta Georgia
Millersville Pennsylvania
Philadelphia
uh Austin Texas
I got great weekends coming up you did
your Penance with uh with uh Long Island
Long Island I had a great time despite
that okay uh you know a lot of great
weekends coming up uh after that
Indianapolis blah blah blah morrell.com
shows nice yeah I'm all over the road
I'm in Nashville I'm like right I'm
nipping at your heels here I'm in
Nashville I'm at Appleton I'm in Brea
I'm at uh the Buckhead Theater in
Atlanta we're gonna try a theater
it's a ways away but please for the love
of God buy a ticket because I'm
terrified
uh what what else is going on and I got
Arlington improv in Texas I'm always in
Texas Albany Funny Bone West Palm Beach
Providence Rhode Island Madison
Wisconsin and uh Rochester New York tons
of stuff we got specials on YouTube
rooftop I got this out to lunch uh tell
a friend get on the patreon we got a
whiskey coming at some point
yeah Chris get on it fat cat it's gonna
be great
it's a rye so get a get a rye thing
cooking in your head already start
brewing we got some recipes ready for
right now hell yeah you want to give out
your plug our social Hey listen uh I'm
Dan I'm at uh 51st and 8th at Dolly
Varden with a V okay you guys want to
come by and try some drinks at uh Mark
and Sam have a hat here come on by there
you go and Gotham studios in New York
City I love it here I mean this studio
is looking insane we got the Patrick
Ewing thing up we got Dangerfield we got
poly walnuts yeah I mean this is madness
keep sending us stuff at Gotham Studios
we'll drink it yeah we'll uh yeah yeah
oh we got should we shout out the uh the
stuff we got sent we got sent the uh
pickles and stuff right oh yeah where
those pickles go uh some guy uh three
dogspickles.com sent us a bunch of stuff
says stay pickley we got onions we got
pineapple it looks incredible I you know
I love pickled anything oh yeah same
same you could pickle a dick and I'll
eat it
this is garnish for next episode please
dude absolutely your magic there man we
got a we got a recipe sheet coming for
that as well I love it and keep
listening tell your friends I'm loving
doing this make sure you subscribe to
this new YouTube channel leave us a nice
rating on uh the podcast app iTunes
wherever you're listening and uh keep
listening hell yeah
we might be drunk
we might be drunk as long as we are
hanging out you know we might be drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
Rex and a bit maybe drunk we
we drunk
here